[cheerful music]
♪ ♪
- HEY, HEY. HOW YOU DOING?
- HOW YOU DOING?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
- HEY, WHAT'S UP?
- HOW YOU DOING, MAN?
[laughter]
- COME ON--
[laughs]
- COME ON.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
- HEY. HEY, COME ON, MAN!
STOP IT.
STOP IT, STOP IT!
- HEY, HEY.
- STOP IT.
THAT'S FUN.
- THAT'S FUN, I LIKE IT!
[overlapping chatter]
I'M HAVING A FUN TIME.
OW!
[overlapping shouting]
YOU'RE BIG!
- [panting]
- HEY, HEY!
- I KNOW YOU, I KNOW YOU!
- OH, YEAH, I REMEMBER YOU.
- I THINK I LIKE YOU.
LET ME--
- YEAH.
both: NO! NO! NO!
- OH. OH.
HEY, WHAT YOU EATING?
WHAT ARE YOU EATING?
- GET THE [bleep] AWAY
FROM ME.
- OH, BUT THAT'S FOOD.
- [bleep] OFF.
- THAT'S FOOD, THOUGH.
- [bleep] OFF!
- YEAH.
[laughs]
I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THE WAY YOU LOOK.
YOU LOOKING GOOD TO ME.
[sniffs]
YOU A DUDE, SORRY.
- THAT'S OKAY!
IT HAPPENS!
- HEY!
WHAT'S UP THERE?
IS THERE--
IS THERE SOMETHING UP THERE?
- YES, YES.
- IS IT UP THERE?
HEY, COME HERE!
- I WANT TO EAT YOU RIGHT NOW.
- YOU'RE UP THERE!
YOU ARE UP THERE!
- I WANT TO EAT YOU.
- NO! NO! GET OUT!
GET OUT OF HERE!
GO, YOU CAN'T HAVE IT!
- I WANT TO EAT IT!
- I SEE IT, COME HERE!
[applause]